4まし
はいいいですか
はいですねちょっと彼氏は切れたんですよすいませんあそうですか
その現代技術ですよねそれでは亡きがの僕はね日本に9年住んでたんですよ
仕事も日本でしてですねだから
私の場合はですね必要があったんですよ仕事のために非常に役に立ちましたとそれ
部分その
日本人が英語を勉強する理由に近いわけですよそれはチャラ女に必要があったと5用と
いうかまぁいえばはダヴィが必要はなかったけども日本語ができたことによって私の
いろんな商売取引がやりやすく無い
処理は
商売の話だけじゃなくてもう夜さの飲みに行ったりとかね
いろんな幅広いそのチアチアが悪いです
あのコレクションうことによって非常に闇立ったわけですよ
で待ってからマックさんから見てですね日本人が何のとどうしてだって日本は100
1億30万ですか13000枚1億3000万の人がいる日本語で10番
通じるわけですよね暗黒でまぁそうですよね
まあな風土して日本人が
英語を勉強しないといけないんですよ
mars 酵素の勉強する必要はないと思ってるだけなんですよねみんながみんな日本
人がそのみんな日本語
絶対英語を勉強する方がいいとは思ってるわけじゃなくてでも多分その
まずコフマンさんみたいにその仕事の上で8つの役に立つ場合はやっぱりその
ビンその英語を習得した方がいろいろその
まあ仕事の機会が増えたらやとかその後情報が取り入れやすくなったりとか
なのでそのまあだから今たぶん日本人の多くはもう日本語ディック者って英語できる
ようになりたいと思っているわけですからそういうもうすでに
できるようになりたいと思っている人たちにちゃんとその政党して欲しいんですよね
その英語の習得にん
それでじゃあ第2のテーマですね
その
文化的憧れかその仕事か
そういう実写医者の何ですか
実際的にまあ必要というか非常に役に立つようなそういうその動機で勉強する場合にも
関わらずですね
限定車せずにですね何が一番効率的な勉強法ですか
あそうですねまぁこれはインプットだと思いますねインプに限ると思います
でインプットっていうのは実際にその習得したい言葉を実際に聞いて読んで少しずつ
吸収していく
で最初はもう理解することに集中するんですけどでもあるある程度理解できるように
なったら多分自然とそのうちもなお
スポット食べる事も書くこともできるようになっていくと思うんでやっぱり
インポットに集中した方が一番効率的だと思いますね
全く同感ですねそれで日本でのその勉強方法ってどんなどんな英語
農相の勉強方法か一番ま
不変でいいですか一般的ですか
今そのですか日本で今日本でまぁ多分
まあ日本人の中学生と高校生はみんな英語を勉強すると思うんですけれどもでもこれは
受験のための勉強であって本当の英語の勉強じゃないわけなんですよねうん
なのでそのまま看護を大量に暗記したりだとか
その分布の方程式を暗記したりだとか数学みたいな感じで勉強していくんですよね
日本語で考えてそういうその暗記した看護と方程式を使って何とか英訳したりとかでも
それとその僕がさっき痛みた
にそのインプットとしてし吸収していくプロセスとは全く別のものなんですよね
しかしまぁ僕はあのご存知かどうかすみませんけども日本に9年住んでたんですよね
70年
まじ12年までなんですよね
それからまあ
80年代のよく日本へ来ましたけど最近は全然行ってないんですよね
だからもう今でも時々に本部使うときにちょっと
a
苦労してるんですけども
しかし日本でエイ前20年前かなってや20年前かに行った時にですね
本屋さんいきますとねその
多読多聴とかインポつが大切だとかねそういう意味の
その本はねどうやって英語を勉強するかとかね
沢山のぞいううんうん読んでみればねぇ
そのインポートが大事だということは日本で誰も知らないというわけじゃないんですよ
酔う村よりに関する本があるんですよ
でなぜ磯の基本的にその英語の音教育システムと教育制度というか
ぽいくとかその辺が全然変わらないみたいですよね
そうですよねそれはなぜだろうね僕もちょっとそれについてちょっとおかしいなあと
思ってるんですけれども
でもどうしても誰も皆固定観念があるんじゃないですかね
やっぱりそのだってインプットっていうのはやっぱ
聞いて読むだけでそれで獅子自然とできるになっていくっていうのはある意味
ものすごく不思議な現象なんですよね人間なのでそれはもう生まれ持った特権みたいな
ものなんですけれども
でもやっぱりみんな例えばその数学をそのやってる先生を見るだけで自分が数学を猛
練習せずにその手記を見るだけでそのできるようになっていくというわけではないじゃ
ないですかやっぱり
自分も練習して自分で考えないといけばにならないわけで多分みんな阿蘇かま数学とか
あとまあ何スポーツだったりとか
その楽器だったりとかそういう間て自分からそのインプットだけでなくて最初から
アップとし
しないとできるようにならないのでじゃあ言葉も同じやんだろうなってたぶんみんな
そう
を思っちゃうわけなんですけどやっぱりことっていうのはそういう他のその技術とか
スキルとはちょっと違うんですよね
だ
そうですよねまあ私の経験からそればですねやはりその
まず1つはですねインプっていうのはその理解力ですよねそうだからこのアイアンより
ぐカンプリ変身ですよね
それが一番大事だと思うんですよで
その自分がする何か良い il
にしてもですねその返事がわからない人ですね
前々回はできないんでしょ全くその通りですね
非常に浮遊かな感じになるんですよあの私のもありますね
自分が言いたいことは非常に苦労して中掛け言えないけどもなんとかなるわけですよ
しかし開いている
いうこと
私わからない人ですね以上の here もう何の意味もないですよね
ねだからもう還付練習が理解力はまず第一だと思うんですよ
で
まっつさんを言うようにですねもう大量のリングによってですねその言葉を習得する
なら
その細いその文法とかいろんな説明はもう考えずにですね
もうほんの的に話ができるようなんですよ
で
それが上台マンなんか村熊経験してあるんですよ
だで例えば日本語はねもう日本語のその勉強するための方ミョムトですねもう色んな
分母的な説明があるんですけどそうですよね
あそういうものは自分の王者の日本にまちゅらー qs でたんだけど勝利によって
いる
同じと話をしてだんだんとこう私の
マーケッ犬だらけの欠点だらけの日本語が女じゃないかまぁ通じるんですよ
そしてお相手の言うことは彼のわけですよ
それでグーなんですよで保育でもねやはり
といけてますねその返事も早く出せないという
ないでしょだからね何ですか反応て基本の的に応えないといけないわけですよ
11その文法のルールを考えたら
あれでスターもう全然ダメなんですよね
だからまあ我々はまあそういう意味ではもうインプットの縦横線に反してはねまったく
同じ意見ですよね
ある空面白いですねじゃあその倉庫不動産が言ってるのはその
なんかその試験に合格したいっていう目標を持っている人でもやっぱり in ポッド
に基づいている
その学習法ととがうまくいくってで楽なんですよねうんヌーナー唐松山
アニメに対して興味あったとじゃあ僕はあるですか
歴史に対して気を見合うて言えばですね興味のあるところに集中すればいいわけですよ
そしてまあある程度はその号医療ですね増やすう意味ではですね
少し子守備反映か広げていけばいいわけですよね
それらの
あのをその分野のその何ですか
専門要望勉強するそれがまぁ一応なわけですね
有賀毒族の会社に勤めていればそれなりの本やの真鯛技術よう勉強しないといけない
まあそれならまあそれに関する
まあポッドキャストを聞いたりとか本を読んだりすれば
それでいいわけでしょ別にその
プッシュの english business english ギター学いかなく
ても
でももしかしたら何か日本人ってちょっとまあ苦労したから行っていいますかその取る
努力を美徳とするところがあるじゃないですか
だからもしかしてや楽しみながらでも学べますよって聞いてちょっとなんだろ多分
すんなりと入っていく
ないんでしょうねやっぱり動力して勉強するっていう
やっぱそれをがもうすでに頭の中にあるわけですからだからちょっとこういう
インプットには中に基づいてるなんか楽しみながらでも学べる方法はなかなか日本人に
はその
受け入れてもらえないかも知れませんじゃあね暑夏日本だけじゃない
ねもうもうやり
これがビジネスモデルと関連があるわけでしょ学校というものはそれが教えるところ
ですよね
だから学校でいかにしてその生徒をその独立管
ところその主導権をそのその勉強する人の方
に落ちるというようなことはですね学校は
なかなかやりたくないんですよね嘘だと儲からないですからね
わからないですよね ok 第三も同感ですから別に議論するところないんですよ
じゃあ今英語以外の言葉
まあ例えばまあ私は日本に住んでたるわけですからまあ日本語を勉強したわけです
けれども
しかし何のために他の外国語を勉強するか
まずよですねまあ英語まあ僕みたいにそのメディカみたいな国に生まれ育って英語しか
できない人はやっぱり少なくとも1つの外国語覚えたらそれでものすごく世界というか
シェア
あっ広がると思いますねどうぞ僕もうだと日本語と英語はあまりにも違いすぎてあって
その日本人は
なんかアメリカ人の絶対言わないようなことを吸うに行ったりするじゃないですか
だからあそっかその北一問その英語しかわからなかった時は安価本当にこういう一つの
考え方しかできなかったんですけど
ああこういうない方もあるんだって知っていくことでもうものすごく運だろその視野が
広がったし
here 日本一安全世界
トップなぁ
まあ一番さん母国語
が日本人っていう各所の数が壊疽のネイティブスピーカー guards 日本語が
ネイティブスピーカーとしてその人間の数はですね多分
まあトップ10に入るんですよまぁそうだよね光永組じゃないんですよね
で巨人まあ僕はそういう小さいな小さい国の言葉でも勉強するわけですよ
それはまっの言った通りですね
やはりシェアを広げるという意味ですよね
はいえー
待ったなぁそのあるですよまあアメリカ人としてのそのものの考え方ですね
今度今日本位まあ日本人じゃないけども
日本語を通じてもう一つのものか考えた部分の
その考えていることを感じていることこれを表す方法ですよね
表現する方法とかねそう
いうまあ経験してですねあのマークという人間がもう少し大きくなってるわけですよ
そうですね確かに伊佐の外最大選んだからまぁ僕の場合はですねやはりちょっとその
完全主義者じゃないんでしょ言葉の勉強においてはですね
だか
ラ
自分今最近勉強したその言葉の家ですねあまりうまくできない言葉でも
モスもさらにひとつ新しいの挑戦したいと
まあ知りたいと最近アラブ語とかいらん語を勉強してね
その
アラブ語とかファー c ですねあの
イラン語を勉強したことによってですねあまりよくできないけれども恒例ラーの人たち
に対する考え方は私のそのアラブ人のイメージとかイラン人イメージが変わるわけです
よ
そしてそれの底あのわれわれ人間としての
さん
ものの考え方人間の顔というか人間が何かっていうのがね
一つのなんていうんですか目えー
医師が変わってくるんですよ意識がね認識あるほどするがやはり言葉を勉強する
一つのなぁあるですよあの
ん何ですか利点っていうかだからそしてまあ人によっていろんな
周囲が違うから僕はそれが好きだから
誰かな
プロセス自体を好きじゃない人はですねまぁそこまで苦労しないと思いますね
そうですねもう僕の考えはやっぱりその
まあ一つの外国を少しずつ勉強することにはもちろん利点はありますしひとつや2つの
外空港に特化して何年も勉強し続けることにも良い点があってデート地をするかは
やっぱり1まあ性格的なところは大きいと思いますね
ここ日本語だけ
じゃなくても子供の頃から結構完璧主義的なところあって
まぁ自分でもなんかあんまりに完璧を目指ししすぎると逆に幸せになれないんでそれは
ちょっと
直そうとはしてるんですけれどもやっぱ性格的にはいつも何か一つのことを極めたいっ
ていうその欲望があってそれでやっぱり日本をやるときも者
本をとっとこともやりたいでもやっぱりそういうちょっと何か病的なまでに完璧主義
じゃない人はやっぱりそこそこまでしたっていうの全然いいと思いますね
まあそれは選択ですよいよねとっすねなぁ一つの言葉
まあいるであろうがリングであろうがそれよもう完璧なところまで猛勉強したて
突っ込んでいきたいというのはで無限ですよね
8そうですね近しい世界中の言葉の数も無限じゃないだけども
何千もある自分の能力に比べても無限ですよ
だけで何ですね
ターン前じゃないんですよ何ですねだからそれはあくまでもう中その興味とか自分が何
た
何をやりたいかというのによって違いますよあのーもうシスター鉱脈というアメリカ人
してますが知ってますしてます安藤はすごい子はもう何ですか
ドジくらいのいろんな言葉をで
ているんですよしかしまぁ完璧じゃないけどもそれだけの彼がいろいろ
いろんな言葉まあ訪ねてみたわけですよねそれはそれとしてのあのあれずたちが学校の
あの人の動画を見てみればですねもうものすごく楽しんでいることが
まーすっはティ
俺
かといってじゃあ日本語ですねもう歴史的ないろんなの文化や4色やりたい人もですね
あれも楽しみですよそれなりの興味趣味があったら女だから別にこれがいいとかあれが
悪い人が言えないわけですよ
あそうですよこの同感ですま十人十色ということで
そうだと所のしようと思えばまあ人生を割りと長いんで両方ももしをと思えばできると
思うんですよね
例えば僕はもう今8年近く日本語を勉強してるわけなんですけれども
あと2年ぐらい日本語勉強してでもちろん完璧は無理なんですけどでもまあわりと
うまくなったとします
それでも僕はまたその26戦になっている
でも風呂以上アクセントのなってからもそれからはいろんな他の外国を少しずつ勉強
することもできますし
なんかもう
しようと思えばかなりどっちでもその両方でも受けると思いますねそうです
それそれをかなえるだけでですね
楽しみなんですよ例えばもっと深くですね日本語を勉強したいならいくらでもあるわけ
ですよ
あるいはいろんな言葉を明記をしたい
7影響でもあるだからやはり非常にまあ
楽しい考えですよだからっ
5分からいいいいましてね言葉の勉強ですね例えば
日ごとのために勉強してもですねまぁ私日本に住んだゴールそれだ頃あるいは日本人が
ね英語勉強するといいですね
その実際的な目標があってもですね
トリック
何百点を取る取りたいとかその
会社に入りたいとかしかし家に楽しくやらないとうまくりさがいいですよね
あってもそう本当にその通りだと思いますねやっぱり外国号ボールっていうのはもう
ものすごくものすごく長い道のりなのでやっぱりあるある程度情熱がないと絶対続け
られないんですよね
で情熱いうのは
理屈でもそのどうにもならないんでん
でままそうですねマークさんはそれこそ情熱
持ってますよねはいキャッチねひとつじゃあそのあれですよ情熱というのはねあーある
布団や僕はその何や英語が日本人が英語に対して全然情熱がないとか
しかし算数号でですねことわざがあるんですよ
らペティギュア音まあ所
すなわちたミラーが食べながらですね食欲が出るわけですよ
だから6個下にいないとダメなんですよやってみないあの鐘
ブログで食欲っていうか情熱が出てくるかもしれぬ
それだったらなんか今はそのだって今の日本では例えばですねその留学生とに高校生
みんな
あるある程度英語勉強するわけじゃないですかでもその勉強法はちょっとそのあれー
なのでやっぱりんだろ楽しくないわけでしょ
なんかもうちょっとそういう学校が使っているその勉強方法をもっともっとインプット
に基づいたものにスリ変えればねぇもう中学生が多くてみんなその
まーすかなっても少しくらいはそう
というその外国語習得を経験できてもしかしたら食欲でる人はその出るチャンスも
ちゃんとあって
そしたら
うんをのであの表はですね木者の短期的な目標はですね
もう理解だと
だから別に圧力がないんですよ別に話ですの正しく何か英語でそのアウトプットいうし
なくてもいいよ
ただその単にいわゆる味わうだけですよ
そして理解理解力はですねまぁ合意を少しずつ増やしていけばですね
処理の方がですねその満足感というかまあやったと分かったと
ってそういうようなですね a 満足があったらですねそれがやはり
理恵
何ですかね水中回食欲の一つのつながりにもなるかもしれないですよねそうですよね
やっぱその物差しをどれだけしゃぶれるかじゃなくてどれだけ理解できるかっていう
ことに移すことが鍵なんですよね
どうですくらいあらタイムシフトをその起こせたらいいんですけどね
いやー
われ
我々二人ですね日本のその英語
教育のシステムもなんですか革命しましょう
起こしましたねアクメの頑張りましょうやりましょう ok
じゃあ今日はどうも長い話動画やはこちらこそまた話せて嬉しかったです
じゃ
たようなら